shocking video released earlier today
showing a three-month-old puppy rescued
from a hot car on the top floor of the
bellagio parking garage police say the
dog was inside for nearly two hours with
its mouth taped shut while the animal's
owner went inside to gamble sasha loftus
spoke with a local rescue group that
wants to stop something like this from
happening again sasha
denise this happened here on the strip
back on july 20. now the local rescue i
spoke with say this kind of thing is
really tough to see and they want to
encourage anyone struggling with a pet
to surrender it safely
where's the dog it's a startling video
being shared across the country with a
lot of saliva security rescuing this
three-month-old puppy from a hot car on
the top floor of the bellagio parking
garage i think it's horrible police say
the animal had been locked inside for
nearly two hours with its mouth taped
shut the high temperature that day
113 degrees it's sad that people just
you know think that they can do stuff
like that and get away denise sear tells
us this was devastating to see
especially since she has a dog of her
own put your hands behind your back
officers say 50-year-old raul carbajal
whose arrest was shown here is facing a
felony animal abuse charge but local
rescue groups like southern nevada
animal rescue link want others to know
this is never the answer they need us
and that's what we're here for managing
director kaylee campbell says no matter
the situation someone struggling with a
pet can always surrender to a local
rescue or shelter even when we're full
we still try
our very hardest to help so that they
aren't in that kind of abusive situation
diana wants others to remember any
animal you get is a commitment and she
believes in harsher consequences for any
kind of mistreatment i think the law
should be stricter
mgm resorts released this statement
thanking the guest who spotted the dog
inside that car and notified the
bellagio security team to get him out
metro police say that puppy is still at
animal control receiving treatment now
as for carbajal he posted bail and is
due back in court next week reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now